what we're going to do in this video are
some real quick tests to see if these
three random numbers are divisible by
any of these numbers here and I'm not
going to focus a lot on the why of why
they're divisible we'll do that in other
videos but really just to give you a
sense of how do you actually test to see
if this is divisible by 2 or 5 or 9 or
10 so let's get started so to test
whether any of these are divisible by 2
you really just have to look at the ones
place and see if the ones place is
divisible by 2 and right over here 8 is
divisible by 2 so this thing is going to
be divisible by 2 0 is considered to be
divisible by 2 so this is going to be
divisible by 2 another way to think
about it is if you have an even number
over here and 0 is considered to be an
even number then you're going to be
divisible by 2 so and over here you do
not have a number that is divisible by 2
this is not an even number this 5 so
this is not divisible by 2 so I won't
write any 2 there so we've gone through
the twos now let's work through the
threes so the to figure out if you're
divisible by 3 you really just have to
add up all the digits and figure out if
the sum is divisible by 3 so let's do
that so if I do 2 plus 7 plus 9 actually
let me we could let me just write it out
plus 9 plus 5 plus 8 plus 8 what's this
going to be equal to 2 plus 7 is 9 9
plus 9 is 18 plus 9 is 27 plus 5 is 32
plus 8 is 40 plus 8 is 48 and 48 is
divisible by 3 but in case you're not
sure so this is equal to 48 in case
you're not sure whether it's divisible
by 3 you can just add these digits up
again so 4 plus 8 is equal to 12 and 12
clearly is divisible by 3 and if you're
not even sure there you could add those
two digits up 1 plus 2 is equal to 3 and
so this is divisible by 3 this right
over here let's add up the digits so we
can do this one in our head pretty
easily 5 plus 6 is 11 11 plus 7 is 18 18
plus 0 is 18 and if you want to add the
1 plus 8 on the 18 you get 9 so the
digits add up to 9
digits let me do this enough so these
add up to nine add well they add to 18
which if you which is clearly divisible
by 3 n by 9 and these two things will
add to 9 so the important thing to know
is when you add up all the digits the
sum is divisible by 3 so this is
divisible by 3 as well divisible by 3
and then finally let's add up these
digits 1 plus 0 plus 0 plus 7 is 8 plus
6 is 14 plus 5 is 19 that is 8 yet for
19 so that we summed up the digits 19 is
not divisible by 3 so this one we're not
going to write a 3 right over there it's
not divisible by 3 let's try 4 and to
think about 4 you just have to look at
the last two digits and to see are the
last two digits divisible are the last
two digits divisible by 4 immediately
you can look at this one right over here
see it's an odd number if it's not going
to be divisible by 2 it's definitely not
going to be divisible by 4 so this one
this one's not divisible by any of these
first four numbers all these first few
numbers right over here let's think
about this 188 is that divisible by 4
and you could do that in your head
that's 4 times 22 so this is divisible
by 4 now let's see 4 goes into 60 15
times and then to go from 60 to 70 you
have to another 10 which is not
divisible by 4 so that's not divisible
by 4 and you could even try to divide it
out yourself 4 goes into 70 C 1 times
you subtract you get a 30 four goes into
30 seven times you multiply then you
subtract you get a two right over here
as your remainder so it is not divisible
by 4 now let's move on to now let's move
on to 5 and this is probably you're
probably already very familiar with this
if your final digit is a 5 or a 0 you
are divisible by 5 so this one is not
divisible by 5 this one is divisible by
5 you have a 0 there so this is
divisible by 5 and this you have a 5 as
your ones digit so once again finally
this is divisible by something it's
divisible by
five now the number six the simple way
to think about divisible divisibility by
six is that you have to be divisible by
both 2 and 3 in order to be divisible by
6 because the prime factorization of 6
is 2 times 3 so here we're divisible by
2 and 3 so we're going to be divisible
by we do that in a new color so we're
going to be divisible by 6
here we're divisible by 2 and 3 so we're
going to be divisible by 6 and if you're
just divisible by 2 or 3 just one of
them then you wouldn't be able to do
this you have to have both a 2 and a 3
divisibility by both of them and here
you're divisible by neither 2 or 2 nor 3
so you're not going to be divisible by 6
now let's do the test for 9 the test for
9 is very similar to the test for 3 sum
up all the digits if that sum is
divisible by 9 then you're there well we
already summed up the digits here 48 48
actually is not divisible by 9 if you're
not sure you can add up the digits there
you get 12 12 is definitely not
divisible by 9 so this thing right over
here is not divisible by 9 and this one
over here if you added up all the dish
we got 18 which is divisible it is
divisible by 9 and I'm running out of
colors so this one is divisible by 9
they're all the digits add it up to 18
and this one over here you don't even
have to add them up because we already
know it's not divisible by 3 if it's not
divisible by 3 can't be divisible by 8
but if you did add up the digits you get
19 which is not divisible by 9 so this
also is not divisible by 9 and then
finally divisibility by 10 and this is
the easiest one of all because you just
have to see if you have a 0 in the ones
place you clearly do not have a 0 in the
ones place here you do have a 0 in the
ones place there so you are divisible by
10 here and then finally you don't have
a 0 in the ones place here so you're not
going to be divisible by 10 another way
you could think about it you have to be
divisible by both 2 and 5 to be
divisible by 10 here that your you are
divisible by 5 but not by 2 but
obviously the easiest one is to just see
if you have a 0 in the ones place